start number 11 coming off a loss at
coors field his last time out on
saturday
a couple guys in this cardinals lineup
that he's had some issues with in the
past including paul goldschmidt has 69
career at bats against the mad bum i
think he's probably got something for
goldie tonight cardinals six over 500
they're in a dead heat with the cubs for
the national league central league
edmond
takes second base
a stolen base for tommy edmond on the
pick-off attempt and that's one of the
other things for madison bumgardner is
his average
to home plate is two seconds
he's just slow he first moved him he
made a bad throw i don't think he gets
him if he makes a good throw i would
agree
in steps to former diamondback paul
goldschmidt the one
and goldie lifts a high fly ball into
center
le castro with the catch tommy edmond
will tag up paul goldsmith has driven in
his 28th and it's one nothing cardinals
yadier molina delivered his sixth
go-ahead and game-winning rbi last night
in the tenth inning as the cardinals won
5-4 the pitch is swung on drill down the
left-field line a fair ball to the
corner carlson is off to the races he's
around third base being waved in
peralta's throw to the infield the relay
to the plate carlson scores standing
it's a double for molina and a two
nothing cardinal lead in the first
inning now tyler o'neal holmert in his
first game off the injured list last
night
o'neal
fly ball
left field
trick whoa
tyler o'neal does it again with a
two-run blast four nothing st louis
what a start here for the cardinals
the fourth spot against madison
baumgartner
o'neal up to 10 home runs
back-to-back games of the home run
and his new season high with 10. johann
oviedo making the start tonight jimmy
yeah this is one of those guys he's
looking for
his first major league win and that's
going to be tonight i have a feeling and
he's going to pitch better and his
hyundai pitch arsenal
he's got a great
great arm great arm but i think the only
knock right now for him is he's going to
have to come up either throw find
another pitch or throw something else a
little bit more the curveball he throws
15 of the time but he's gonna have to
have three pitches in that 30 range or
20 percent range you know where you got
to really you got to get a hitter to not
really know what's going to come
alton knocks it into right
they're going to wave rojas here's the
throw from thomas a little offline and
josh just sneaks by molina
and there's your run
rbi for peralta
away checked on that one and that bum
gets his first strikeout
[Applause]
right makes another sliding grab out
there
and they stray on the two out walk
feedbacks and the cardinals diving back
freely
[Music]
pulled left side arenado the turn now
dropped by edmond
and with oviedo struggling to find the
strike zone that
has to be at least one out even with the
hard hit ball the castro can fly this is
something that you don't ever see
i might never see this again he just
whiffed it so carson the former cardinal
hit one deep to the warning track and
left his first time
high in the air it backs up thomas in
right ahmed is at third
and here he comes the castro tags up as
well
and that's an rbi the lead is cut in
half
2-2 pitch to nolan arnado
out to left
pretty well hit
near the wall did he get enough gone
nolan oranato has gone deep
how about getting your hands in on that
one i'm telling you that's two ways to
look at it either got to get in there or
you don't swing i mean
how did he pull his hands in like that
and hit a home run some of the times
that he puts the ball in play
it amazes me that's his third against
madison baumgardner he pulled the arms
in went down to get it one and two on
josh reddick
that bounces off of edmond
they're gonna wave peralta here's the
throw it's offline and it's 5-3
and the 1-1 pitch
chopped towards third arenado steps on
the bag and got him
what a play
nolan arnado turns two
he's hit a home run tonight and now this
dandy
talking dandy for sure wow oviedo went
crazy this is what i love come
on on one and two a base hit into left
they started the runner that was thomas
he'll score easily
that makes it a 6-3 cardinal lead on a
base hit by tommy edmond dylan carlson
hitting 267 with runners in scoring
position
and the 2-1 is hit out to deep right
field
that ball is down and it's a ground rule
double for dylan carlson dive into the
pool and get that souvenir
i feel like when you get that close you
either want to win or lose you just
don't want to come out of the game
guys don't want to come out of the game
anyways but
the swing and a miss that sinker holy
moly
we're not hitting that
no one
when you do that's just
more bonus for you as a manager good job
by jake woodford
back-to-back case in relief of oviedo
0-2 pitch
and a cold third strike
four strikeouts for woodford coming out
of the pen
7-3
pavemen smith stay hot
well you called it earlier he's putting
these doubles in the absolute perfect
spots and this one is going to be a
triple
i mean you talk about splitting the gap
he's hitting these centered right down
the fairway face is full two down for
eduardo escobar
that one gets through la castro is home
they wave martay here's the throw from
thomas it's cut off and it's a 7-5 ball
game in order escobar
knocks in two
david peralta will be at the plate he
represents the go ahead run swing and a
miss he struck him out
pot strikes out peralta with the game on
the line in the bottom of the eighth
inning
orinata with a high drive
into left plenty of deep goldschmidt
will score
that is manufacturing a run right there
and it's an 8-5 st louis lead
bounce to first it backs up goldie
they get one reddick is home and it's
8-6
2-2
on the ground
slowly hit so sad got him
and the ball game is over
eight to six the final and a great play
by sosa to end it